[موسيقى]
قطعت هذه التحفة الفنية النادرة أكثر من
4000 ميل وتم
فحصها نهائيًا قبل تعليقها في
متحف اللوفر أبوظبي بقطعة أخرى
رسمها المعلم الهولندي يوهانس فيرمير على نفس القماش ،
وستكون هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يتم
عرضها فيها  جنبًا إلى جنب خلال أكثر من 300 عام ،
نحن كثيرًا ونأمل أن
يكون هذا أمرًا ممتعًا للجمهور لأن تلك
اللوحات الجودة المطلقة لهذه
اللوحات هائلة ، فهي واقعية
لا تحتاج إلى معرفة الكثير من أجل
الاستمتاع بقطعة  للفن الهولندي والقرن السابع
عشر
، يحتل Vermeer مكانة مرموقة في
أحدث معرض عن العصر الذهبي الهولندي ، حيث
يعتبر الاثنان معًا في هذا
المعرض في أبو ظبي البذيئة
لحظة فارقة ، هذا جديد حقًا
ولعب الفراولة التي
تشرف على هذا المعرض هي
روز ماري المنسقة الرئيسية.  لذا فإن الأمر كله يتعلق
بمشاركة هذه التحف الفنية مع جمهور جديد
فقط لجعلهم يساعدونهم معًا
فقط لجمع الكثير من القطع الأخرى
معًا هو أمر رائع حقًا.  ليس فقط
هنا ولكن في العالم ، هذا أمر مهم
بالنسبة لنا فقط لعرضهم
وإدراجهم في الضوء ، يتعمق المعرض في أعمال
أساتذة هولنديين مشهورين مثل Rembrandt
Yen Leoben و Jihad المكونة من 95
قطعة  بما في ذلك 15 من
لوحات ورسومات رامبرانت ، فهي تعرض
أكبر عدد من أعماله التي تم
عرضها في الشرق الأوسط على الإطلاق nova
Willoughby لدينا نوعان من
العناصر الألعاب التي تمثل أكثر
من ستين بالمائة من الزوار و
40 شخصًا هم المقيمين في
المعرض  يعد الامتحان قويًا ومهمًا جدًا
لأسماء روائع الأشياء التي
يمكن أن تبرر في حد ذاتها رحلة إلى
القدرة منذ افتتاحه قبل أكثر من عام بقليل ،
وقد اجتذب المتحف أكثر من مليون
زائر تسلط مجموعته الدائمة
الضوء على الموضوعات والتأثيرات العالمية
تصدرت أبوظبي عناوين الصحف العام الماضي من خلال
الدفع  رقما قياسيا عالميا 450 مليون لنا
دولار مقابل أموال ليوناردو دافينشي سالفاتور
وبينما ينتظر عالم الفن
بترقب كشف النقاب عن تلك التحفة الفنية
عبر المعارض الضخمة
مثل هذه الحشود القادمة
إليك